and I'm going to be talking about some
relatively unholy things here so you
know so how do you integrate like Scala
and Jai phone scholar and like Java with
your Python code so a little bit about
me I'm Marius get out that Twitter that
because there's a double underscore
speakers Python right so I'm a software
engineer / data scientist at max point
and so why would you want to do this
right so you know we we do we do things
where we integrate sort of see and like
Python all the time but why would you
why would you want to do Python and Java
that's like the JVM is like its own
magic magic world and it's kind of hard
the main reasons is like you're working
at a at a big company or you know really
big company and you have you know
millions of lines of Java that people
have written over you know decades and
you know so you want to use that stuff
because some of it is probably pretty
good I mean some of it maybe isn't but
you know you still want to be able to
integrate that stuff without having to
rewrite it in C or or Python to go and
make use of it and you know the JVM is
relatively fast it's not as good as C
but you know you can get some pretty
decent performance from it and there's
some there are some nice sort of
high-level languages that exist you know
on top of the JVM that give you a lot of
things so how would you do this so the
first you know way where you can do this
is you can do this wire sort of some
remote procedure call system so you know
this sort of the the thing that that's
touted as the sort of the
service-oriented architecture where you
have some some pies and process and it
talks to some java process over a
protocol so apache thrift rest protocol
buffers you know this many and this
obviously adds some complexity because
now you have to like have an entire
system dedicated to managing that sort
of communication protocol stack and you
need to go build tools tools around that
so that's kind of heavy weight but you
know ultimately it's
probably not a bad idea you can use
Jason shouldn't use Jason because Jason
is not a real thing it's like I mean you
can get it but it's like great now I
have something that sort of like vaguely
looks like Python but I can't import
numpy ever so that's a non-starter or
you can use pipe or J which sort of you
know there are some people that don't
like pie for J but it does sort of what
it does relatively well when things
break you will have fun times because
now you have like fun pythons fun
jealous stack traces inside your Python
but you know once it's sort of like
working okay you're pretty good to go
and so PI for J it's a remote procedure
call system as well so it's still you
know doesn't try to do something crazy
like embed java inside the python
process space because that's really hard
and there are people that have tried
that and it always fails so it works
quite quite great for like standard Java
code things but you know a little bit
more coercing is required for making it
work nicely with Scala you can probably
do closure with it as well I haven't
bothered or tried but so a simple
example of how you would do this is if
you have pie for J installed and you
have a JVM installed and those things
are required obviously so you can
basically import a java gateway you can
start a java gateway there's a whole
bunch of additional parameters that you
can pass their of city of setting up how
your java class path works and things
like that that's an exercise to the
reader and you can get sort of a JVM
handle and I can actually just call like
Java util random which is a Java class
that gives me a random number generator
and I can call functions on this this is
all pure python so what exactly is going
on here so when you do this it launches
a subprocess and your python process
will talk to that thing over a local
host socket
and it uses a weird you know magic
communication mechanism that's like
specific to pi/4 J only that's sort of
some of the annoying parts of it and
when you call java de utilidad random
that sends a message of that socket
telling instructing your java process
that sits on the other side there please
go make me an instance of this sort of
via java reflection and sort of hold a
reference to that thing around and
return like basically just an integer
back to the Python person saying by the
way I made you this object is object
number five and your Python process can
then use that to talk back to it and
then we call a method on that the same
thing happens where you send sort of the
Python process since sort of an integer
saying on object number four call the
method called next int with these sort
of argument types so it all sort of
serialize all of your arguments into
something that Java can understand so
all primitives are done and then lists
and dicks automatically get converted as
well and sort of standard Java like
types and I'll try and find a method by
via things call it and sort of do the
same proxy sort of object magic that is
required for Python to sort of know
about your result if it can be or if it
can be converted back into a pro into a
Python primitive LLL go do that as well
so if you have a function that say
returns an int then Java ins will get
converted to python dance and vice versa
so working with primitives you know is
relatively simple and if you're doing
pie for j stuff that's probably you
probably want to stay there just because
when you start dealing with lots of java
objects it can become a little
complicated to know really what's going
on because your code still looks like
python at that point but it really isn't
so using this we have we can use all of
python there are no constraints on which
libraries you can use so as much of as
much numpy sort of numpy see extension
fun times as you want and you can use
every Jolla library
so that's kind of nice so others like a
lot of cool things you can do with this
and so the largest sort of standard user
of of of pi/4 J that's sort of popular
now is apache spark so apache spark it's
a distributed computation engine sort of
written in scala and it has some python
bindings called pi spark so that you can
write your sort of your big data
distributed processing thing in inside
python because you know data scientists
don't really like writing lots of Java
and Scala so you know we'll try to avoid
it so you know they were kind enough to
provide us with you know python bindings
and all that the python bindings really
are is you know is it's basically just
calling out to making a java subprocess
and using pi for Jane talking with it
and so dealing with Python types it does
with some pickling and you know a fair
bit of sort of magic using there's a
there's a library called cloud pickle
that it uses for sort of serializing
things like closures which you know
pickle doesn't 0 eyes closures and maybe
at some point they'll switch to dill who
knows but so what what goes on when
spark does this stuff so so you make a
python process and this python process
sort of says okay well i need to go talk
to talk to apache spark it'll make you a
child java process and i'll go and talk
spin up some kind of other java process
possibly on a different machine probably
on a different machine and it all sort
of in it'll talk to it via by a sort of
a standard standard out thing and the
python process actually talks back to
the java process via socket so it's this
crazy sort of interconnected layer cake
of pieces that's all kind of terrifying
but luckily you probably don't need to
care about the internals of how that
works except when it breaks because now
you have now you have a Python stack
trace inside a Java stack trace on a
remote machine that will get that maybe
you ulong you hope but it's sort of a
it's okay so PI spark is using this sort
of pi Forge anything and you know we can
just use this we don't actually have to
use spark or you know rely on the
internals we can provide our own things
to it the only thing that's sort of
annoying from the pie for genocide is
Scala right so Scala is you know in many
ways basically just a better Java
because you know Java programmers like
writing lots of lines of code I assume
they get paid by the character scholar
programmers are seemingly the opposite
they hate writing characters so your
code is nice and purse and it has lots
of nice functional things and it's easy
to do sort of highly expressive code
much like it is in Python the sort of
machine learning libraries aren't quite
there yet which is why you'd want to
sort of work inside Python mostly for
doing your data science work and then
sort of Scala maybe for doing production
sort of sort of production data
pipelining and you know sort of you can
get you can get by with us and it works
faydee okay so in order to deal with the
annoyances that is scala i wrote a
little library called spy lon to sort of
punt menu of scala python you know and
you know and and it makes it easier to
interact with Scala code from pure
python so it provides a bunch of
conversions for simple for simple types
and some import helpers for dealing with
sort of scholar constructs so Scala is a
thing called called an object which is
similar but not quite the same as as a
Java static class so you'll need ways to
get those things because you're probably
wanting to use them if you're if you're
writing so Scala code and you want to
use that from inside spark and and
Python and because spark is a very big
user of Scala a whole bunch of like
helpers is also part of this force or
making it easier to work with apache
spark so if any of you have tried to use
like Apache spark from within sight from
within an eye Python notebook it's
relatively painful to get like all the
configuration correct because there are
parts of the configuration that you that
that you need to set that are you know
that our magic environment variables
that are relatively poorly documented
and you know we'll just do that for you
so that you don't have to care that much
anymore and it also sort of some
extensions that deal with running some
running applications on my sauce and
yarn in custom custom anaconda while
custom content environments so that you
can just sort of say well I need to run
numpy version you know one point 11 on
my cluster I'm not going to go install
it by hand everywhere because that's
really hard so let me just have some
mechanism that I can provision that
entire environment over the over my
entire cluster at runtime and build that
thing sort of on the fly as I submit
this I'm at all and that sort of mostly
adapted from from some blog posts by the
guys at continuum and it allows you to
sort of get up in cap and going pretty
quickly and easily so let's go into what
what the stuff actually looks like in
real life
so because I'm not that brave I'm not
going to do life could live demos sorry
it's hard for me to see from this angle
okay so cool so so spy lon is heavily
sort of inspired by by apache spark but
you don't actually have to use spark to
use it for sake of for sake of the demos
and making it easier to just have a JVM
around that has the necessary scholar
libraries to do this stuff I will be
demonstrating it using sort of spark as
as the sort of as the Java side of this
but it's not required if you want to use
the scholar pieces obviously you need a
JVM that has the necessary scholar
libraries around so top bits are just
sort of boilerplate JVM helpers is sort
of the pieces that tells us that allows
us to sort of interact nicely cleaner
with the JVM so some simple calls so
we're going to make you know that same
that same dinner I made around I made a
random thing here and I'm gonna print
out what that looks like that looks like
that that's not super handy because you
know that just says R and what but
what's that it's like what can I do with
this and
I forge a sort of sufficiently good that
sorry it'll actually print out you can
still get documentation on like exactly
which methods exist what types to call
them with sort of so that you can know
what's going on and have like full
introspection obviously you don't get
things like you can't get things like
dark strings because Java is kind enough
to compile them away because they're
just comments so that's sort of annoying
but you can still get a lot of details
on like I have this R and I have this
round object it has these methods I can
go call them and it all works so for
example I can call Randall next int and
I get a number i can call it again and
this this is all running on a JVM that's
a subprocess of of this of this thing
and then sort of some simple conversions
because you know at some point Scala has
a couple of like of sort of key
collection types that are not the Java
collection types so it has it is a thing
called a Sikh which is you know
analogous to analogous to a list so when
you get one of these I can convert
standard Python list into a Sikh and I
get this thing once again a Java object
nice and opaque but you can call methods
on it that sayings like what is this
thing really now like the actual class
name for these things looks terrifying
and horrible that's just sort of mostly
an implementation detail of how
scholarworks and generally you shouldn't
need to care but if you want to you can
just go look at what what's actually
going on and you can still get like a
nice representation front of it it's
like that looks like a list so you can
still get some sort of you can get it
and sort of standard in standard things
that sort of make sense to you and the
same with you know
I can do I can do dictionaries and you
know get get these sort of structures
that that exists on so that I can easily
sort of jump jump to to the scholar side
of argument types when I need them if
you you can also just call standard Java
constructors which is what we is what we
what we did up here is java de utilidad
random is just a class name and it
happens to be that this class has a
constructor that takes your arguments so
you know you can still do all that stuff
and it still doesn't look that foreign
to python users I mean that's a pretty
long string of things there but that's
sort of okay so what if we don't want to
do you know something something cooler
right I mean converting controverting
things is is all fine and well but you
know what I've actually want to like so
whatever I want to you know actually
write some code so let's let's do that
so I'm just gonna make a directory i'm
going to call it hello scar already
exists but you know that's because i ran
this demo before and I'm gonna just
inside the notebook just make myself a
simple scholar file and this is just
standard Scala code it looks a little
weird but there's not that much to this
I'm basically making a singleton called
hello scholar it has two methods it is a
method called say hi that returns string
and it the string is just high and it
has a methods that sums two integers so
not a particularly complicated example
so we'll go print that and and we can
just go compile this so I'm compiling so
I'm just running running svt which is
sort of scholars compilation tool but
you can use whatever you want and that's
going to spit out to me you know a jar
file
so in the same way previously where we
imported we where we sort of imported
this source pylon and sort of started a
effects effects park thing that we
weren't using for spark just because it
happens to have an interpreter around we
can also just add jars that we need it's
like please add this to the to the Java
process when it starts up so that we can
import our cloths that we just defined
up there so starting this step stuff up
will take a little while and it's going
for the helpers again and we'll just go
import our scholar object that we've
defined it's called hi has a doc string
just like we saw previously and we can
go call methods on this so you know in
like very very little amounts of code we
wrote like some JVM code so compiled if
the Scala and just called it with very
very little effort from from a Python
process and that's kind of cool and you
can clearly see that you know if you
have if you have more complicated
systems that you that you want to
interact with the same process applies
there's nothing there's nothing there's
nothing particularly weird or magical
about this and you know just to prove we
can actually pass arguments because I
haven't you can just call methods and it
works and you know
this is all you know fairly standard so
the main reason why we why we probably
want to do some of these things is you
know particularly with respect to with
respect your apache spark is defining
things like if you have sort of
user-defined transformations that you
want to run inside the JVM space keeping
those things inside java land is much
more efficient from from sort of you
know a runtime behavior so in that in
the
or I'm going to jump back a bit so ah
really fine
so in this process if you're if you're
running this this distributed code at
the at that point where your where your
your java process is talking to the
Python process this is serialization
thing that that's happening there that's
not free and when that Python process
talks back to the Java process there's
another serialization that happens there
which is also not free and then you know
when this running program talks to that
Java program there's some more
serialization so you have all of these
sort of serialization gates there that
you pay a toll for every time you use
them and that toll can be expensive so
you know in so in as much as possible
what you would you what you'd like to
have is you'd like to set up a system so
that your your Python logic which sort
of dictates the flow of how this thing
is going to operate that can all be
inside Python and when you encounter a
bottleneck that something is slow you
can take that tiny little piece there
and you don't need to go rewrite
everything which is the standard
behavior that people seem to like doing
it's like just just keep your Python
code it's fine there's just at once one
slow piece and you can just rewrite that
little bit inside inside scholar and
using pi for j you can just link all of
this stuff up as you would as if you
wrote the entire thing in it but it's
like oh i'm just going to call out to my
sort of transformation function that
knows how to do this and that's sort of
a powerful abstraction that gives you a
lot more sort of flexibility in in how
you structure in how you structure sort
of efficient code if your program if
your data is not particularly big you
know you can do whatever you want
doesn't matter at that point
like that it's it's just sort of when
you see her alive when you see realized
easier eyes large amounts of things all
the time it adds up and can add up to
sort of 10x performance penalties which
is undesirable to say the least so
oh right great
what's it Oh
so just because this is still a lot of
it is Park West I'm going to serve one
or two kind of neat little features of
this inside actual and running actual
spark so spark is like a billion ways of
doing configuration and in order to get
it correctly working there's like 200
parameters or so that you need to tune
because big data so that's fun what are
they well they're all like vaguely
undocumented that's also fun so you need
to know these magic strings on the right
side at least we can on Python do some
things where oh I can now find that I
have some setting called spark executor
dot you know logs whatever and I can go
see see what what that means and you may
get sort of a description of like what
all of these settings mean what their
what their behavior is in fact this
looks like I had like an instigating so
but the rolling logs look like
and all of these are just just lots of
configuration but you can get some
details and you can configure all of
these insects sort of behavior of how
they work and that's sort of nice for
having sort of more pythonic things
rather than giant dictionaries of these
big ugly keys that you carry around all
the time so I'm going to do the same
boilerplate again so if you so who here
is actually used apache spark within a
netbook how many of you love the fact
that you don't have progress bars you
know because you're going to run a job
it's going to take an hour maybe who
knows so but and you get the progress
bars when you were running in like the
scholar shell so why can't we are those
the answer is well we totally can so
this is just a simple example I'm going
to run a little thing that basically
sleeps and does nothing so I'm going to
run that now and this is the standard
thing that happens when you have a spark
of that runs right seal the star there
and you kind of watch to see if that
star changes and it's not change yet so
you know who knows what's going on I
mean you can go look in the logs of your
Jupiter terminal and you realize this
law lots of stuff going on you but you
have to go look at that so you know it's
finished now but I would have liked to
know you know when's that gonna be on so
let's turn on some progress bars so
you know we can actually do things and
I'll tell you what's going on like
that's sort of you know and none of
these things are particularly
complicated to go implement it's just
you know pi spark is sort of to a degree
you know a you know well it is a second
class part of the spark ecosystem
because you know it's all written in
Scala and there is this this piece but
you know we can easily do things where
we where we as the community can can
sort of provide additional tooling to
make lives better for for us all and
that's sort of you know a lot of what
what I'm just trying to trying to do
yours you know we're all writing these
sort of internal things that make that
make it sort of better for better for
sort of us individually our companies I
think we can we can you know get
together and sort of formulate a plan of
like how can we move the Python side of
the stuff forward foster and you know so
I'm gonna have to run through the whole
deck again hey so how do you get this
stuff it's on github it's kinda
installable it's pretty easy and we are
welcoming sort of new contributors to
the project if you want to help out and
do and do some of this sort of like
unholy fusion madness there's there's a
lot of interesting things that you know
but that we that we have have in the
pipeline so some of the things that are
that I've been thinking about is is we
saw how we are relatively simple it was
to just run or just like compile some
Scala code on the fly and just inject it
we can just make standard Python
functions that allow you to do this and
maybe even do maybe and even do
completely crazy things like do Python
AST transformations and go and just make
you make you write Python that isn't
really Python so these are all sort of
things that can be done whether they
should be done as a completely different
question but it's sort of there's a lot
of interesting interesting piece pieces
that sort of exists in this sort of
strange intersection space between sort
of into big enterprise sort of software
and sort of you know [ __ ] data science
and you know I think it's a pretty
exciting space to be so with that I'm
going to open the floor for some
questions is there hold on give let let
eric to this job
testing does spy lon provide for the
dynamic compilation you did it but you
did it manually yes does spy lon give
you the ability to generate the generate
that code and and do the compilation
programmatically not yet it's it's
something it's so the project's still
quite young so we started it about two
months ago so there was a sort of and so
I've been I've recently be doing a lot
of work on Apache Tory which is a
scholar Jupiter colonel so the actual
mechanics of how you would go about sort
of doing this I know how they work it's
just mostly mostly a question of like
putting in the time and and getting some
pieces going right now spy lon is is a
pure python library in order to get that
stuff to work we'll probably need to
need to include some actual java as part
of this
so thank you we're going to have to cut
this short because we got started a bit
late so let's thank our speaker and